I hear that I'm over 40 I'm pushing 50
whatever bring it back off negative not
happening in fact stepping it up
training harder eating cleaner
I'm training I'm learning and reading
and studying more now than I ever have
in my whole life do I get dinged up of
course I do
you know what no factor no factor deal
with them
either what you want height here I hear
the clock ticking that's why you
is nigh and time waits for no man and
you young guns out there
18 years old 20 years old 24 years old
listen life goes by
goom's
waste those years don't waste them live
them
[Music]
to be 30 much less 40 but you are and
you will in the earlier you get in the
game the better life you better have
healthier wealthier stronger smarter
better better if you but an old man like
me then you haven't gone on track yet
get on track you don't it now
here's the deal no complacency no
complacency no backing off
no slack whatsoever fight
fight that ticking clock with everything
you've got
so
a heart big
put your head down
[Applause]
satisfied
[Music]